okay next caller is from the two-five
three area code caller from 253 tell us
who are you where are you calling from
and what's on your mind today
hey this is John I'm from Tacoma
Washington all right go ahead and one
kind of talk AB done hey just want to
kind of talk about the net neutrality
bill okay just in the fact that this all
ended um I guess I'm curious about how
you build that's gonna affect your
business personally considering you guys
are more of a dress with new stations
and talk about these kind of things
Schumer's report also does and make a
fire and specular talk and mainstream
you need basically thousand and now I
guess my question is do you feel that
these companies that whoever your
personal providers can model you guys
personally and these other organizations
that might be against their a better
business
I guess practices or do you feel like
you bill fight leave you alone and let
you guys do business as normal or
basically something like that I am very
scared of the repercussions of the net
neutrality repeal I think that if the
net neutrality repeal does not hurt
progressive independent media it's
because they don't bother trying to hurt
us I think if they want to hurt us they
can hurt us and hopefully we will just
float under the radar and not become a
target but yeah I think that there's a
three pronged and I mentioned this
earlier in the week there's a three
pronged attack on progressive
independent media right now number one
is the repeal of net neutrality number
two is further media consolidation an
example is the approval of AT&T buying
Time Warner and number three is hyper
normalization which is that when Trump
was first elected and YouTube D
monetization hit media independent
progressive media shows like ours
suffered or not suffered experienced a
huge resurgence people saying we got a
deal with this Trump stuff we've got to
deal with YouTube D monetization I'm
gonna support the David Pakman show and
the other shows that you mentioned it's
been a year now scandal is becoming the
status quo and that combined with net
neutrality and media consolidation it's
an uphill battle for independent media
that I wish I could put a better spin on
it but yes I am
I am scared about it and all I can do is
continue to activate for what I think is
right
yeah I think so too and I think as long
as everyone's obviously supporting guys
like because from me in myself I get a
lot of my news from from you guys
because you guys talk about a lot of
issues that mainstream you it just
doesn't or isn't allowed to
which is probably more that's okay yeah
I mean yeah thank you I really
appreciate the call I appreciate you
pointing to this issue and we're gonna
keep talking about it because it is a
massive massive issue